welcome back to the heat basketball on
Fox Sports unchristian Hewitt here with
you we have a unique to Wayne way love
connection to share with you tonight
they met in 2012
Duane way and they've seen their icon
twice
their lives meeting Dwayne predicted
that the next time he saw them they'd
have a baby and here he is
last night Wayne Wayne had a chance to
meet his namesake Freeman Wayne in
person at the season ticket-holder event
and I'm here with the Lu family now I
just want to ask you what was that like
for you last night to see Dwayne Wade
your icon you're here holding your baby
Raymond Wade
it was ultimate a dream come true for
our family not only for us but also for
little Raymond it will be a moment that
he will remember for his lifetime oh he
lost his that phone Sarah let mommy put
him back on now what is it about Dwayne
Wade that both you and your wife really
love what is it that you admire about
him oh he's a great teammate on court
but also he's a humble guy loving Ben
softcore he spent time with us giving us
a special moment and most important he's
always a father first
so we met him the first time at his
father first book signing and now we re
taking some notes from that book he is a
great dad if you were ever gonna take
notes from to take parenting advice from
him thank you so much for spending your
time with us and have fun watching the
last time ceremony control all right
Eric and John I've never seemed to three
more devoted fans of my life guys thank
you Chris in there that that young one
there looks like a future Kids Day
participant